good morning everybody
I've got a tiny bit of the flu so I got
a lot of tea and the microphone is too
volume okay for everybody up down bit
about it's good it's good all right so
uh well as you said I'm an analyst which
is different from psychoanalysis but
since I'm Austrian as Sigmund Freud if
you've got any questions about
psychoanalysis feel free to come up
afterwards in the meantime I'll tell you
about one of my favorite stories in math
and it's also one of the oldest stories
in all of history it's three thousand
years old
and it's actually so old were not quite
sure what it happened but I like to
think it did what do you see in the
picture is died oh it was a queen in
what's now called Lebanon and so were
here and she ran into some sort of
political difficulties right that
happens so she took her people and she
fled all the way to what's now Tunisia
and back then had an entirely different
name and tried to get a fresh start
right and we know about this story from
virtual and he's not the most
trustworthy narrator so as I said we're
not quite sure what had happened but he
tells the story as follows he says died
with her people arrived in Tunisia and
spoke with the local king and said
you've got a lot of space here and
there's a lot of empty space I need a
fresh start I've got a couple of people
I wouldn't need too much could you give
me some of your land and the king was
not a nice man the Kings that ah well
yes of course I would give you land as
much land as you can cover with this
t-shirt and he gave her well he didn't
say t-shirt he said ox-hide because it's
3,000 years ago but he essentially gave
her a t-shirt and said you know you can
put it wherever and that it's going to
be yours
all right it was not a nice man but she
was very smart and she was one of the
first mathematicians and what she did
you can see here she told her people to
cut the t-shirt up enter a really long
loop they said okay okay whatever is
covered by the t-shirt is mine so she
covered she took the tissue
and cut it into a long loop e-string
okay and then once you have that loopy
string the problem is how do you arrange
the string on the ground
so here's here three possible diagrams
the black lines are always the long
loopy cut of t-shirt and then it's on
the ground and there are many different
ways you can arrange it on the ground
right there's many possible shapes you
could choose and the question is which
one do you choose and she said we'll go
for the circle because the circle has
the largest area and that makes it a
first mathematician one of the first
mathematicians and she's absolutely
right so among all sets in the plane
that have a certain fixed perimeter
fixed boundary earth boundary with a
certain fixed length that you cannot
change right you cut up the t-shirt and
that gives you a loopy string of a
certain length and you cannot change the
length anymore you've cut up the t-shirt
you've got the thing there the only
thing that can change it is the area
inside and the way to make the area
maximal is to arrange it in the form of
a circle right so this is a pretty nice
statement it's also very old statement
and you can feed another way there's
always two ways to think about things
until the second one is you fix the area
and look at the boundary and say among
all sets in the plane with a fixed area
you know everything has you can put that
on a square with area one you can put a
circle of area one you can put a hexagon
it's a regular polygon with six sides
it's the one in the middle you can put
that down all of them are going to have
a certain a fixed area and then the
boundary length is going to be the
smallest for the circle right so this is
it and it seems like a beautiful
statement it seems like the story should
be over now while it's not first of all
this fundamental fact has been known by
nature for a very long time I'm talking
millennia what do you see here is the
fat that's swimming on top of the soup I
don't know if you've ever taken a closer
look but it's a bunch of tiny circles
it's a bunch of tiny it's also the
tastiest part I think but it's a it's a
bunch of tiny circles and it's a bunch
of tiny circles for the very same reason
and nature goes even further than that
so if you have a look at this beautiful
animal
I mean if you have a cat at home that's
how cats lives I think some dogs as well
any idea why yes
oh yeah no this did no one's disturbing
this one right it's so cute and if you
look on top right it's a perfect circle
right bingo bingo also not being
disturbed that's important right you
like your sleep no this is its way the
analyze the least surface area so it's
not exposed to the cold weather as much
and animals have non dissolved all along
I mean sleeping in a perfect circle and
you know this too right you know how I'm
lying on the beach on the beach I'm like
this and when it's winter and I've
walked to the office I'm walking like
that because I'm decreasing surface I
don't want to be exposed to the wind
this is how you do it and of course in
the captain of the other turnaround so
this is the family cat in summer you
want to increase your surface area you
want to be as far away from a circle as
possible all right so here's here's a
political question I don't know whether
there's any princess or princesses here
but where would you like to be king now
Queen while these are two possible
kingdoms to choose from and let's say
say they're both equally nice say the
same amount of nice rivers and beautiful
mountains with a couple of lakes the
only thing that's different is the shape
they're also equally big same amount of
gold right so which one would you choose
for the enemy to get there yes
congratulation as the Youngman is
perfectly right all right so here's my
troops I've got four soldiers right I'm
a small King I'm happy to a full
soldiers at all and they're patrolling
my boundary then if there is a sort of
invasion happening I like to be in the
circle because in the circle I can
reroute the troops whereas in the long
thin strip I'll never see them coming
now I may be I'm simplifying things a
bit and probably I am and maybe I'm not
so here's a map of Paris
16:15 you see the city wall perfect
circle
let's go further this is a map of Europe
and I would have I would have taken a
map of the US but the u.s. is not
representative because the US doesn't
invade itself a lot but Europe invades
itself a lot so here's a couple of
shapes in Europe their common estates
let's look at the circles in there
there are many and again now here it
should say and maybe I'm oversimplifying
this a bit it's not just a matter of
geometry because you know if you've got
mountains that increase separation you
have sociological facts such as people
like to be ruled by a king who speaks
the same language right there are many
reasons some some countries like this
and countries like that so I'm
simplifying when I say it's the shape
but the shape does contribute and you
can see it contributing so one
interesting fact is that Italy right
Italy is not the circle at all it's a
boot shaped form but if you look at the
part of Italy that's boundary with the
rest of Europe that part here is where
you actually meet your neighbors it's a
perfect circle and see
right getting an actual circle is very
difficult because in the end people say
let's take this river let's take that
mountain those are nice borders right
Italy is very long very true that's just
a boundary and the same goes for France
Frances if you look at the part that's
bordering with the rest of Europe is
approximately a circle again I don't
want to oversimplify too political
political facts but it is a first
approximation and here's something I
found while looking this up on the web
so this is a discovery made a year ago
apparently if you put something that's
vaguely circular shaped on the ground
and here it's a cellphone charger then
cats like that and they will sit inside
so someone discovered this I guess by
chance you know you drop the cell phone
cable and suddenly the cat is sitting
inside right and you repeat the
experiment and the cat is still sitting
inside so someone put this up on the web
and then of course people started
experimenting with their own cats and it
seems to work very well and it's not
quite clear why because you know a cell
phone cable doesn't offer you increased
protection that was the first theory you
know increased protection yeah this is I
mean the cops are not protecting you
from the dog but maybe cats like nicely
shaped territories and I've seen this
experiment repeated with bananas we put
three bananas the cat will still sit
inside and it even works for a couple of
other animals but not as well so it
seems like cats is really the one cat
like circular shapes and if you've got
cats at home I'm sure some of you do
give it a try okay here's something
completely different and again you will
see the circle as a dominating shape
this is serious science it's so serious
that it has a complicated name it's
called the internal diffusion limited
aggregation model but what it really is
is a game you know you can say oh I'm
going to work and play games you like
I'm doing serious science so here's
serious science for you you start in the
center and that's the rule rule number
one you start in a Red Square
and then you go into a random direction
you go up or down the left or right
completely randomly and whenever you hit
a square that you've not seen before you
color it green and go back to the
original red point let's play a game
again
so we'll take a random step I don't know
where it's going it's going right okay
now we go back to the Red Square and not
a random step okay we go up back to the
Red Square and not a random step this
time it's left go back to the Red Square
we take a random step starting from the
Red Square
okay we've gone up but we've gone up
before right it doesn't count we play
the game until we hit an empty square so
what do we do now are we go left okay
well I mean it's ran all right you throw
a coin or a dice we go back to the Red
Square and now it's down back to the Red
Square we go down again but we've been
down before so we keep playing the game
again and again we go back up again okay
that can happen we keep playing left and
now yeah okay so this is the game and it
models cellular growth and these sort of
things are a growth of crystals it's a
growth model that studied by physicists
it's also a fun game what happens if you
play this game for a really long time
well number one you'll get bored but
number two you can use computers to
actually do it and this is what you get
after a million steps and the funny
thing about this is I mean it's clearly
a circle and it makes sense that it's a
circle right because if you've got
something that's close to your Center
but you've not been there before you're
sort of likely to go in there right if I
withdraw it whenever you've got a shape
like this all right and you start here
you're pretty likely to go in here and
then back to the square and here and
back to the square and here and back to
the square and then you will turn it
into a circle and if you zoom in on the
boundary it's actually quite interesting
it is not straight it can't be straight
it squares and it gives you a sort of a
weird landscape that's pretty rough and
that is still not properly understood so
understanding that landscape is an open
problem
very pretty one
okay back to math so die the statement
says among all sets in the plane with
the fixed area of the circle has the
smallest boundary or conversely if
you've got a fixed perimeter length the
circle has the largest area and the good
thing about math is you can always ask
why
right so the teacher tells you it is so
and you can say why why you can always
keep going there has to be an answer and
I've not given you any sort of answer
I've told you that it is the case and
that it appears in nature a lot but that
might mean very little so what's the
actual reason and someone might say you
know you've given us all these nice
examples from from nature
so certainly nature knows best right
nature has been implicitly thinking
about this for a long time this is an
example of an ice that is hexagonal so
it has it's a regular polygon with six
sides
if you go online you'll see there's
actually a lot of different types of ice
and one of them has hexagonal shape
here's another and more striking example
so my favorite planet Saturn and you'll
see oh it's perfectly round right it's
another circle yeah it is until you swim
in on the north pole so here's an
example here's a picture from the North
Pole of Saturn you see a hexagon there's
a hexagon on Saturn and no one knows why
it was discovered rather recently no one
has any idea where there should be a
hexagon on set and it seems to be some
sort of storm that's raging on and it's
twice the diameter of Guth it's huge and
it seems to be like a sort of tornado
that stays there for hundreds of years
but why is it hexagonal shaped why is it
not a circle well you see there are
things in nature that I'm not a circle
so just saying that it happens like that
it's not it's not sufficient reason to
say it's gotta be the circle
but why would there be six different
directions of wind
why not seven why actually here we don't
know but for the circle we do know
that's a good part of the story so as I
said the story started two thousand
eight hundred years ago and it took two
thousand seven hundred years to complete
it's a really long story and the first
result is by Sen odorous about whom we
know very very little but who set the
following is as if you've got a triangle
with certain lengths and you built the
triangle that use it up the same amount
of boundary area so in the story of
Queen Dido you cut up your t-shirt into
something that's you know this long and
you can build through two triangles out
of this you can build this triangle
maybe not quite and you can build this
triangle and they use the same t-shirt
and Sena Doris says that the second one
has a larger here you know okay so
that's one of the first step it says
that being more regular increases your
area which makes you a better candidate
and he showed the same statement for
polygons with four sides and five sides
yet again this means very little right
there life is not made up of triangles
if it was just triangles we would be
done by now but we're not because there
are many many complicated shapes but
this was a first step and he is
remembered for that after 2,000 years we
know nothing else about him we know he
did that and then for 2,000 years there
was nothing there was absolutely nothing
people didn't know what to do it he had
no ideas it's a very tough problem and
then the the sort of the the main hero
of the story is Jakob Steiner who was a
Swiss mathematician around 200 years ago
and from what the sources tell us the
right picture is more accurate he was a
pretty angry man so he would you know
vaguely argue for something it's gotta
be like this it's gotta be like that and
then if you say but why he would get
very angry and scream at you but Marc
but he had one absolutely brilliant idea
which is called the Steiner
symmetrization and it's so brilliant and
used so much that people actually
dropped in him and say so much
because it's clear that he did it and I
want to illustrate it with a slice of
pizza
so what Steiner did is he was just
playing around with geometry he was just
having fun with shapes and it discovered
something absolutely amazing it is
discovered a game that gifs takes a
shape that makes it more regular it's
called the Shriners symmetrization game
and it's played in a very easy way you
take your shape you take a line and then
you take the lines that form a 90 degree
angle let's save this and then you cut
it along those lines so you cut the
pizza in slices and move the individual
slices up and down to make them as
symmetric as possible with respect to
the black line you move this one up you
move this one up this one up just one up
this stays a bit it goes down okay now a
new weird pizza shape which clearly has
the same area right I mean you cut a
pizza and move it around the area if the
pizza doesn't change luckily for us and
you can do it with more complicated
shapes as well so the game here is you
start with the shape on top you cut it
along those lines and then you move
those lines to be as symmetric around a
big line as possible I'll do one more
example here
so I'll take the letter a because why
not you start with any shapes of the
shape
and you take one big line it doesn't
matter which one it is you can take any
big line you like okay and then once you
have that line you'd cut it up then you
move those shapes up and down to make it
as symmetric as possible so the new
picture would probably look a bit like
you know this one I got to move down a
bit so looks like this this one I'm
moving down a lot it looks like this
maybe this one is pretty fine the way it
is this I got a shrink a little right
this just moves here and these as well
so you got this new shape and if you do
it correctly with enough lines this new
shape will be perfectly symmetric around
the big line and clearly will have the
same area now how does this concern us
it concerns us because it keeps the area
the same but if you play this game the
perimeter become smaller the boundary
shrinks which is great right you've got
a game you start with a certain shape
you get a new shape that that's the same
area but it's smaller boundary and you
keep playing again and you get another
shape and has a smaller boundary still
and another smaller boundary and then on
a smaller boundary so if we just keep
playing this game what happens you get a
circle all right so I mean here this is
not yet a circle right but maybe now
I'll play the game again with this line
and with that line and another couple of
lines and it will start to look more and
more like a circle and once you've
reached the circle the game is over
it's actually you can still play the
game but nothing is going to happen
right because you take any line and if
you cut it up and move it up and down
you'll get a circle back because the
circle is symmetric with respect to any
line the game is over all right so it's
Emma tries with respect to that line and
you get the circle back so the game
keeps on going until you hit the circle
then it stops that sounds pretty good
right we're trying to find a shape with
a certain area that has the smallest
perimeter and we get a game that makes
it smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and when it hits the circle it
stops right so this is what China said
he said I found a game it keeps the air
at the same it doesn't change the area
at all but the perimeter becomes smaller
and smaller while you're maybe stays the
same but it doesn't grow anymore and you
can always play this game until you hit
the circle when you've got a circle the
game stops and therefore the circle is
the one shape that has two smallest
possible boundary because I can't play
the game anymore now is this a good
reason yes no I think it's an amazing
reason I think it's a beautiful argument
but there's a tiny tiny gap and what
I'll tell you now is something that's
it's not complicated but it took the
best mathematicians of the time another
50 to 70 years to realize it's a great
reason but it has a tiny flaw the tiny
flaw is we don't know whether there is a
solution I'll talk about this at great
length no worries so Steiner himself was
completely convinced he said this solves
the problem it's 2700 years old and I've
solved it he was very proud and he was
very angry when you doubted the
completeness of the solution and then
Oscar Pavan came up and he came up with
a great example
so what pellon did is he met at a game
of his own and said
I can do the same type of argument you
do and I end up with complete nonsense
so we gotta be careful
so his game was the following he says
take any number like three it multiplied
with itself okay that gives me in the
Heine
okay multiply that with itself that
gives you 81 okay you multiply that with
itself it gives you a large number all
right all you do to and you get four and
you get 16 you get 256 and so on it's a
very simple game and that one who was a
much nicer man one should say it was
very nice his you can see it he's very
nice he said the following he said this
is a game that takes any number and
gives me a bigger number there is one
number for which this doesn't work
what's the number what's the number
where nothing happens one precisely it's
one nothing happens with the one I fell
on said you know I've got it I've got a
game it always gives me a bigger number
and if I look at the biggest number the
game has to give me the same thing again
like the circle in Steiners game the
biggest number is the one that doesn't
change therefore one is the biggest
number because it's the only one that
doesn't change now that's nonsense right
we know one is not the biggest number
but in terms of the argument it seems to
be and if we compare the two arguments
side by side we see they line up
perfectly so Steiner said two circles
the shape with the smallest perimeter
because he has a game and for everything
that is not the circle you get a new
shape that is better the circle is the
only shape for which you get something
that is not better
therefore the circle has to be the best
shape and pellon says well one is the
largest integer because I've got a game
that takes any integer and gives me a
bigger integer back and the only thing
for which this doesn't work has
manaphy to be the largest integer and
therefore one mr. largest integer it's
quite puzzling isn't it
and actually both are right so Python is
right in saying that if there was a
largest number this argument would show
that one is the largest number and then
everything would break down okay this is
he's sort of intrinsically right
assuming there is a largest number but
there is no largest number and the same
way Stein is perfectly correct in saying
this circle has to be the best shape if
there is a best shape there might not be
and you know this is subtle again people
who I mean mathematicians get very
passionate about these sort of things
sort of ever fights people got actively
angry at each other for believing it or
not believing it and it's a passion of
science so what goes wrong in the second
game what's what's happening in the in
the in the perform game is the numbers
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and to
get more more different from each other
whereas in the Steiner game the shapes
get more and more similar to each other
and eventually this has to be the reason
why it works right now it's not clear
this is the the final mathematician who
appears in the story and he solved the
problem by again devising a beautiful
game and if you stop listening to me
which is maybe you know not a bad idea
you can start again because this is
something completely new and unrelated
it's an entire game in itself and it
clears up all the mystery so this is
blush get Blaschke was the first person
to systematically study convex shapes
and convex is a very fancy word it's
even Greek but or maybe Latin well it's
very fancy in any case and it's just a
shape with the property there from every
point you can see every other point
right every point you pick you find
another point that works perfectly well
and here's an example of a shape that is
not convex so the second shape is not
convex because you can't see from X to Y
that's sort of a wall in between you
know this room is perfectly convex
because I can see everywhere because you
all need to see the blackboard otherwise
it fits the purpose while I can't see
under the feet so you might argue maybe
not
let's take took a look at a couple of
letters so here's the letter D it's
perfectly convex right you can see
everything from every words here's
another nice letter to P please not
convex mighty can't see from here today
there's a wall in the middle yes I
didn't draw it very well that's true
oh you're saying it looks like this then
it is neither that is perfectly true my
handwriting is very bad to my teeth look
perfectly convex nice handwriting the DS
not comics anymore oh that works in any
handwriting okay
okay and here Blaschke came up with the
following amusing insight if you start
drawing a lot of convex shapes with area
one and you try to draw as many
different convex shapes as possible it's
not so easy writing into a triangle and
you can do a square maybe a circle but
after a while your run out of options as
a shape below right that's not convex
and if I'm allowed shapes like this I
can draw many many different shapes all
right right then most numbers are not
convex right so I can write down one
that is a perfect nice shape I can write
down too that's another nice shape and I
keep going and you know I'll be fine
even after like a million three hundred
and eighty one I get a perfect shape and
they're all very easily distinguishable
because I can read numbers but if I
restrict myself to purely convex shapes
it's not so easy because they're not
that many different convex shapes and he
had the following idea he said assume I
were to cover the entire blackboard with
convex shape so I raised everything I've
done and I draw a lot of convex shapes
then you'll be able to find some that
look very very similar by which I mean
if you squint your eyes a little bit
you'll be fine you'll not see the slider
small differences and if you keep
drawing and fill up more and more and
more and more blackboards you'll
actually be able to find two that become
more and more indistinguishable become
better and better so here's an example
here's a Gauss's favorite form our Gauss
was a very famous mathematician and he
liked his shape very much and he
actually said that when he died he
wanted to have this shape on his
tombstone because he most closely
identified with it and the stonemason
said well this is not going to be
possible because the shape is virtually
indistinguishable from circle it really
looks like a circle right so this is one
of the statement if a way to say I start
with a triangle that's perfectly convex
right I think a square so three sides
four sides five sides six sides and you
keep going you have infinitely many
shapes all of them are convex and all of
them are different because you can
actually count them writing okay this
one has 28 shape so it's different from
the one with 29 shapes that's true but
if you don't look too carefully here it
really does look like a circle doesn't
it and it gets even better and this is
this is not maybe a bit philosophical
but this is the reason why Steines
process is working and Perrins process
is not working so I want you to picture
the following game and that's a very
nice game so this is a mountain range
okay we start here maybe this is our
initial shape okay this is the area if
you wish but the philosophical
implications really the following if you
start on top of a mountain and you want
to go down in the valley and you've got
a process that makes you go down such as
Steines game right you decrease the
perimeter while keeping the area the
same if you always go down the thing you
need to make sure is set this down not
an infinite hole all right if there's an
infinite hole you're in serious trouble
because you can always go down and go
down and go down and you'll never reach
the bottom and this is what corresponds
to the biggest integer that doesn't
exist and this corresponds to the shape
that doesn't exist if the circle is not
the optimal solution you'll fall into a
hole so if you actually go down the
mountain how do you make sure that
you're in that situation and blaschkas
argument was very similar like if you
keep walking down and that's the same
kind of cherry tree that you see all the
time
you gotta be in this scenario and the
cherry tree has to be in the center
because otherwise you wouldn't see that
much
if the charity was here you would pass
it once and keep going down and if there
was an infinite hall we would see the
cherry tree once and then it would keep
going down the hall and not see it again
but if you keep seeing the same cherry
tree over and over and over again as you
keep walking down the mountain towards
the lowest point then the charity has to
be in the lowest point right I say if
you go to Florida to go to Disneyland
and you keep seeing Mickey Mouse you're
probably in Disneyland and not lost in
Texas right that's the principle but if
you don't like the sort of reasoning you
can just focus on the game itself the
game itself is given infinitely many
convex shape find two that are very very
similar Wow so I'll give you a couple of
things like this dancing around and I
give you infinitely many you just have
to find two that are very very similar
that sounds really complicated okay it's
something that you might not want to do
it sounds boring and cumbersome and
exhausting but there is a nice little
trick and the trick is called the
pigeonhole principle and I did not come
up with that name but it says if you put
five pigeons into four holes there's got
to be one hole that contains two pitches
all right and this you can apply in many
many settings so suppose you've got the
13 people in this room which room then
have to be two who are born in the same
month otherwise you run out of months
right you can't have 13 people be born
in all different months
even in the leap here you still have 12
months not counting days I'm not
counting days I'm counting months I wish
if it were days yes if you need 367
people to have them all be born on
different days I have to have two people
one on the same day that's true so
here's an infinite version suppose you
have all the integers and you want to
call them with numbers and you have
three different numbers red green and
blue and at least one color appears
infinitely many times how do I run out
of colors right so if everyone appears
at most 300 times after 900 numbers
you're out of colors and if every color
is at most two thousand times you run
out of color after six thousand numbers
and if everyone appears only a million
times of the three million numbers
you're out of color so one of the colors
has to PAP infinitely many times and
this is what will now do we'll take the
shapes infinitely many convex shapes and
we'll devise a way to put them into
different holes and then we'll say one
of the holes has to have infinitely many
shapes so they got to be very similar
and then we look at that infinite subset
and keep refining let me just show you
an example so I've had a couple of cats
already so I'll keep going I'll use this
cat to watch out whether the region of
space is in is occupied by the shape or
not so whenever there's nothing going on
they caught the cat is like a small gas
that's being attention and if there is a
shape that we get very excited and say
ah the shape is here so I'll use 16 cats
initially and if there's a shape the
cats are trained to go where all right
and this is my way of detecting shapes
another shape and then two cats are
trained to meow not a shape
now think about it I've got infinitely
many shapes one shape after another
after another but I don't have finitely
many castes and have a finite number of
ways that to cats can react right to get
me out or not meow and I only have 16
cats it's the same as the numbers and
the color after a while I'll be running
out of react so one of the cat reactions
has to appear infinitely many times so
for infinitely many of the shapes the
cats have to be react in a certain fixed
way suppose it's that one now that tells
me a lot I found an infinite number of
shapes where the cats react like this
what does that tell me about the shape
well you know not so much but not
nothing right so this is one possible
shape that works this is another shape
that works this also works they're still
sort of similar a different but they get
more and more similar so it tells me a
couple of things about whether shapes
could be but it also tells me about
points that cannot be in the set so if I
have a set that makes the cats react
like this it is not possible for this
point to be in there and the reason is
because they're convex so I can see
every other point from where I am
meaning in particular the two cats they
can see each other right this set this
pointer is in the set this point is in
the set so they can see each other so
the blue line has to be in a set and if
this will now assume let's assume for
for a little bit that this were to
actually be in the set and these two
lines would also have to be in the set
because you could see from every point
to every other point and then that cat
would actually have to react as well but
it doesn't and therefore this point is
not in the set and if you look carefully
you see this entire region here cannot
be in the set because it would make that
cat meow and it doesn't all right it
seems still like very little information
but if you lose a lot of cats we can use
a lot of cats right so here I've got a
know maybe a hundred cats and I still
know one of the cat
configurations has to appear infinitely
many times I might be disappointed
then this now tells me up pretty high I
mean this is a pretty good information
already because it tells me the shape
has to be between those two boundaries
so every cat has to be in there so all
the connections between the cats are
also in there and you know if I've got a
pin if I've got a point here then those
cats here would have to meow but they
don't so this point is not allowed in
here and if you play the game carefully
you'll see the shapes that make the cats
react like this are really inside here
and this actually finishes the argument
you just keep adding more cats and they
allow you to detect one shape that
appears infinitely many times and like
the cherry tree in the bottom of the
mountain this one shape has to actually
solve the problem so I'm not saying this
is this is you know this is not an easy
trick right this is a complicated trick
some puzzles have an easy trick and you
go ah but this is a complicated trick in
New York you go well give me a second
time but and it took people as I said
2,800 years to figure it out but the
good thing is if you do these sort of
things along the way you learn a lot of
useful things and you can apply to other
problems so now okay it took us only
almost three millennia to figure out
Dido's problem but let's look at another
problem let's assume Dido has sisters
all right so not as full Queen Dido's
and they have one domain in space say
this black board and they want to split
the black board somehow in a way such
that you get four kingdoms half the same
size such that the boundary lengths
combined our as short as possible right
previously I had one kingdom of a fixed
area oops and I want the air I want the
boundary length to be as small as
possible now I've got four kingdoms or
50 kingdoms and the sum of the areas is
supposed to be as small as possible how
do you do that it sounds infinitely more
complicated well let me introduce you to
Queen Dido and her sisters
bees have that problem forever bees want
to do precisely that you want to split
things into honey combs of the same area
to put the honey in and they want the
boundary lengths to be as small as
possible because you have to actually
build it right I mean you have to
actually build it which is a lot of work
if you've got a complicated boundary
that is very long it takes you a long
time to build it if it's short
you're very efficient so bees seem to
have found the perfect configuration for
thousands and thousands of years and
this observation is actually 2,000 years
old it's goes back to Marco's Terentius
Varro who was a Roman scientist who
wrote about things he saw in the gardens
on the countryside and he says well you
know the honeycomb clearly has a
hexagonal shape no man there's six sides
to the boundary because the bee has six
feet
that's it nicely fits in well no not
quite but this was the first time this
was mentioned and again it's a very very
complicated problem at the solution took
two thousand years and it was actually
solved 15 years ago so not too long ago
in 1998-1999
by Thomas Hales who is still alive and
well and they said the bees actually
right this is the perfect way to
distribute things it's a remarkable
statement is also very complicated
document and there's no reason to stop
there so one example is suppose I
actually give you a square and ask you
to not put it into a lot of small areas
because bees know how to do that I ask
you to put it into four or five subsets
five kingdoms to minimize the area what
does it look like this that we don't
know we have no idea it's a perfect
puzzle and we don't know what to do with
that puzzle we don't know how to answer
the problem just to say there's a lot of
open problems out there that still need
to be solved let's talk about houses
suppose you like bees but we like to
build houses and you know you've got
seven seven kids you want every kid of a
room of the same size otherwise there's
trouble trust me I know and sort of the
houses have the same the rooms of the
same size and you want the boundary
length which is now the walls to be as
short as possible why because they're
expensive to build right if you can
build short walls and can get the job
done those short walls the reason we
don't do it it's not very nice to live
in this places so Kelvin Lord Kelvin was
one of the first to think about this
problem and he said this has to be the
solution this is the three dimensional
analog of what bees are doing in the
plane and it's a very old conjecture and
we still don't know the answer but we
know one thing this is also nice about
math
Lord Kelvin who was a brilliant man I
mean we named temperature after him
right it's a very small scientist he was
wrong so there's at least one
configuration that is better than what
Lord Kelvin proposed it was discovered
by physicists in 93 the pivot
configuration is still unknown
we don't know what three-dimensional
bees would do if these are
three-dimensional but the house is to
build a two-dimensional essentially we
don't know what a three-dimensional bee
would do and another nice aspect of math
is if you get pretty pictures like this
you can sometimes convince people to put
them into reality so this is the Beijing
National Aquatic Center that was built
for the Olympics in 2008 and it's based
on that shape that configuration
here's another problem and this is again
a problem of the following type we now
know there is an answer thanks to the
same reasoning thanks to the same game
with the convex shape it's the same
principle we know there is an answer but
we don't know what the answer is so the
problem says suppose you have a worm of
length 1 maybe you know pet rain worm
and whenever it falls asleep you want to
cover it with a blanket and you like
your worm very much so you want the
cover to be made out there to blanket to
be made out of gold all right sure gold
is very expensive so you're looking for
the smallest possible blanket that will
cover the worm no matter how falls
asleep it's an interesting problem and
you can say that the circle with radius
1 will work because you just put the
center of the circular blanket on top of
one of the endpoints of the worm and the
other side has to be within a radius of
most one the distance of most one so
it's contained fully inside the blanket
all right but that's 3.14 areas that's a
lot of gold if you think smart about it
a circle with radius 1/2 will also work
because you can put the center either
the center of the circle at the middle
point of the war but the middle point of
the war has the property that all other
points are at most one half of it away
distance at most 1/2 from the middle
point so they're fully contained inside
a circular radius 1/2 and with the
little thinking you've reduced the area
by a factor of 4 which is great if you
want to save money now it gets tricky
1/2 a circle with radius 1/2 also works
and the argument is more complicated and
people actually actually kept thinking
about this and the best result is
somewhere in here so we don't know what
the best shape is probably it's very
pretty to look at but we know it's air
is somewhere between zero point two one
and zero point two eight and one thing
that's happening is Blaschke tells us
there has to be a solution because you
get a sequence of convex shapes
we get an infinite number of so stretchy
ticket better and better and better and
better solution you get more and more
blankets and you've got infinitely many
blankets there's going to be two that
look very similar as a matter of fact
it's going to be infinitely many that
look very very similar and they have to
look similar to the real answer so again
the cherry tree in the value of the
mountain and this makes it of course
more tempting because we know there is
an answer we just don't know what it is
that's always bugging me
okay let's return back to nature we
started with the nature of the circle
circle appearing everywhere in nature
and we got a beautiful mathematical
problem out of it so the last few slides
are to convince you that nature is still
amazing and there's still many beautiful
problems that need to be solved and we
don't know why why things happen the way
they happen so this is something you get
when you mix iron get you know there's a
lot of different irons in chemistry I'm
not a chemist I read about some of
Cabiria
but what you have is if you mix iron you
get shapes mixing in that form and it's
called the austenite in the martensite
and it makes in a very very complicated
way you get one entirely on one side and
you get another one that's sort of mixed
up in weird lines that have a certain
ratio and that can be observed for a
couple of materials and people actually
pretty close to figuring out why that is
true but it's one problem that just
appears out of nowhere you try to
understand the reason what is happening
there has to be a reason it doesn't
happen randomly there's some structure
behind it you have to discover it this
is another nice example it's volcano
eruption in Northern Ireland that gave
rise to this constellation there are
40,000 stones like that so the picture
only shows a couple and if you look at
the stones most of them have six sides a
couple of them have five a couple of
them f7 some are for some are eight no
triangles most of them have six sides
it's not clear why that happened so you
have two volcano eruption you've got
sort of lava flowing and it's of
crystallizes in that form it's not clear
white would do that in that shape people
are trying to understand it and there
seems to be some connection
with problems arising in analyzing
images on the computer so completely
unrelated topics might have some impact
on this so here's something that I spent
many years thinking about and while I'm
still thinking about it it's difficult
if you do this you've got vibration in
the desk has one big vibration wave and
that makes a lot of noise and that's
what we hear but on top of this one big
oscillation there's one big vibration
going through the desk there are many
tiny vibrations on top and you can't
hear them because they're tiny but if
you sue me in large enough you get
structures like this and if you so many
to atoms you see the same structure
atoms I really like tiny vibrations so
you get this shape and sometimes it
looks like this and sometimes it looks
like that and to get back to a recurring
theme of this talk the problem I've been
thinking about is how many of these
bumps can there be I had to get a couple
of ups you got a couple of downs his
bumps bump how many bumps can there be I
think the worst case is hexagons like
the bees if this has a bee type shape I
think this is the worst possible case
that can happen but we don't know why
that is true the computer seems to agree
with us and it seems to really be that
hexagons again a purist a limiting case
we have no idea why we need a couple of
new ideas and the final picture these
are liquid crystals that are also being
actively studied and give rise to very
beautiful pictures okay so I want to
finish with saying that there are many
very nice problems in nature that need
to be analyzed that give us shapes and
we would like to understand why the
shape is the way it is why is it that
shape and not another shape that nature
tends to be pretty smart at these sort
of things
so nature's usually right but we don't
know why and in the end you do want to
know why okay thank you very much